what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and moon knight is
well underway we are halfway through it
now and a lot of people seem to really
be enjoying it it's a different mcu
project than we've ever gotten before
but of course it still kind of feels
like a marvel project it has a lot of
really cool aspects to it one of those
including of course the egyptian gods
and i won't spoil it for those who
haven't seen up to episode 3 yet but
there are some really cool scenes in the
moon knight series that involved the
gods and of course concho is a huge part
of it and he is the egyptian god of the
moon and with this egyptian lore being
introduced to the mcu now more than ever
and moon knight stephen grant slash mark
spector slash possibly jake lockley now
being introduced to the mcu as well
people are wondering when the heck does
this take place in the mcu we have no
frame of reference at all as moon knight
doesn't really reference the mcu that
much even with an easter egg in the
latest episode talking about a different
city that we've heard somewhere in the
mcu before that doesn't explain when
this takes place in the mcu as the city
has been around for a very very long
time however thanks to a big easter egg
in one of the moon night episodes it
looks like we have a pretty good time
frame of when moon night takes place in
the mcu we can pretty much narrow it
down to a very particular time period
and somebody from marvel studios did
come out and start talking about when it
does take place and why they don't
really reference any time in the movie
we also have some really cool thor and
black panther connections to talk about
today so let's dive into it and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so right away let's
talk about what one of the moon knight
writers had to say about the show's
vague placement in the mcu timeline it's
actually kind of interesting as moon
knight writer jeremy slater doesn't
exactly know where it falls on the mcu
timeline and apparently that was
actually done very intentionally they
did it on purpose but here's what he
said a lot of people have asked this but
i have no idea sorry we didn't know when
our show would debut in relation to
their other shows and films so the
timeline was intentionally left vague
that's very interesting because moon
knight does kind of seem to be a show
that is very separate from the mcu yes
of course it takes place inside of the
mcu but there aren't really many
connections to the mcu and other
superheroes so it would make sense that
they weren't really trying to connect it
to anything and put it any specific
place in the timeline however like i
said there is an easter egg that does
give us a pretty specific time frame now
this easter egg was found by ryan over
at screencrush so credit to him for this
it's in moon night episode 1 where
steven is trying to stay awake and he's
learning about the egyptian inead well
when stephen is reading up on the ini ad
we can actually see some other books in
the background and they are about asgard
and wakanda however the asgard book
seems to be specifically about new
asgard on the bottom the book appears to
read the history of wakanda but on the
top it seems to read what's old is new
again asgard now we actually know enough
about thor love and thunder from the
merchandising that has been released to
know that after avengers in-game new
asgard is now on earth and they're kind
of an attraction now for the people of
earth and kind of a vacation location
and we know that they do such things as
asgard boat tours and we'll talk about
this in just a minute but what this
really is pointing to is the fact that
asgard being new again as in being on
earth means that moon night most likely
takes place after new asgard is on earth
a lot of people have been debating
whether moon knight is before the snap
during the snap after the snap we've
seen some footage of moon knight falling
from a cliff some people were wondering
if this was moon knight coming back from
the snap after avengers end game well
since new asgard was developed after
avengers in game at the very end of
avengers in game this means that moon
knight takes place after avengers in
game and probably takes place at least a
year after because people are writing
books about new asgard and that just
doesn't happen in a few months now i do
acknowledge that this could be about
when thor actually appeared to earth
because people kind of became aware of
the asgardian gods again because thor
kind of became a celebrity after the
avengers someone could have wrote a book
about it then however the writer did say
a lot of other shows were coming out at
the same time and he didn't know when
this was going to take place and
concerns to them which also does imply
that the show does have a general
timeline they just didn't know what show
was going to be released first and what
the timelines for the other shows were
but it probably means that this show
moon night does take place around these
other shows that were supposed to be
released like hawkeye and she-hulk and
miss marvel all taking place after the
snap and after avengers in-game which
was the five-year gap so like i said
here we have kind of a pretty general
time frame of when moon night is taking
place in the mcu it's taking place after
the events of avengers in game and if i
had to guess it probably takes place six
to eight years after the snap one to
three years after the events of avengers
in game especially because so far the
shows that have come out after avengers
in game have been anywhere between three
months to six months to a year after the
events of avengers in-game as far as the
mcu timeline is concerned not the actual
release timeline but what's really
really interesting is this easter egg
right here the book about asgard and the
book about wakanda and they're
interesting for two reasons as there are
two different books the wakanda easter
egg is very very interesting because of
all the events that are taking place in
moon night in marvel comics the black
panther god bast is a part of the
egyptian iniad and in episode 3 we even
see a statue of bast however the avatar
for bast is not in the meeting and i'm
trying to be vague to avoid spoilers for
those who haven't seen it but stephen
explains that there are nine egyptian
gods in the inead in the mcu and there
were not nine gods in attendance which
means there are some gods missing and
one of those gods missing was the black
panther and egyptian god bast and this
is very interesting and it also does
kind of help the timeline question as
well but what's interesting about bast
being gone and the avatar not being
there is that black panther 2 wakanda
forever is coming out this year as well
and reports have actually said that we
will be seen best again in wakanda
forever this could explain why we didn't
see the avatar of bast in episode 3. the
gods were called together but bast
wasn't there what was bast doing well
probably dealing with whatever is
happening in wakanda forever we know
that bast actually chose the very first
black panther and guided him to the
heart-shaped herb and we know that a new
black panther is going to have to come
in wakanda forever it would make sense
that bast would be a part of this and
this is a sad subject but although we
don't know for sure yet if they're going
to kill t'challa in the film since
chadwick boseman is no longer with us we
do assume that he is going to be dead in
the mcu and rumors of a funeral scene
have been going on so perhaps bast
couldn't make it because she was
attending the funeral of t'challa the
black panther and again this would mean
that moon knight takes place around
wakanda forever if bast truly isn't
there because she is dealing with
wakanda forever events which means this
show probably takes place like i said
between three months to a year after
avengers in game and it's really
interesting that all of the stuff that
we've seen so far for thor love and
thunder shows us that new asgard is kind
of going to be a tourist attraction now
but this makes sense because they're not
rich anymore they don't have a city of
gold anymore on asgard there on earth
now and it looks like they're gonna have
to be making some money to survive but
we'll have to wait and see on that
fortunately we don't have to wait that
much longer for thor love and thunder in
the meantime let me know what you think
about these easter eggs and when moon
night takes place in the mcu timeline
and its connection to black panther
wakanda forever let me know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]